between toby and tom and i where we were
like oh my god like
you find it hard to pee in the suit i
find it hard to pee in the suit
andrew garfield makes a surprising
confession about his
unique spider-man bond with tobey
mcguire and tom holland that's funny
in variety's latest actors on actress
conversation andrew sits down for a
virtual interview with west side stories
rachel ziegler i love those movies and i
love the dynamic between peter and gwen
so much the pair chats about andrew's
super secret role in the latest
spider-man film no way home alongside
his fellow peter parkers tom holland and
toby mcguire i still can't believe it it
happened and that's when the british
actor makes this candid confession
between toby and tom and i where we were
like oh my god like
you find it hard to pee in the suit i
find it hard to pee in the suit and
that's the three spiderman across
universes are sharing a frame together
and like your hair your little head just
explodes the 38 year old actor opens up
to the 20 year old actress about keeping
the big secret under wraps so yeah to be
a part of it was was just incredibly fun
and incredibly exciting and yeah
it was very fun lying about it i'm not
gonna lie it's weird it was weird like
i'm not a great liar but i love games so
like to be able to play a game of mass
werewolf with the internet with like
millions of people like was kind of
amazing he even lied to e.t more than
once about his spidey involvement
there's a lot of chatter of the is he or
isn't he when it comes to the next
spider-man
so let me just ask you i don't know what
you guys then i was like is he
originally what like what's the where's
this going well where is it going how do
you tell me i feel i feel like i'm in a
game of werewolf and i'm just saying i'm
not the werewolf i am not the werewolf i
promise you guys i am not the werewolf
um so yeah i mean
listen what people are talking about
is a really cool idea but when it comes
to andrew's candid reveal he says it
helped him get even closer to toby and
tom there was a brotherhood that got
created between toby tom and myself
and like that's healing as well where we
were like oh my god like
you find it hard to pee in the suit i
find it hard to pee in the seat and
like you know
and deeper versions of that as well and
things definitely got deep when e.t
spoke with the oscar nominee earlier
this month i'm so happy that i get to
talk about it now the fact that i get to
be one of those people wearing the suit
next to
my actual spider-man hero toby maguire
and
the the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spiderman of tom holland and
then i get to be the middle brother and
i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother and just like and
also there's something spiritual that
kind of happened and happens